[Music]
what is up everybody what is up
everybody it's Santa mac and I'm joined
here but my brother's goes down what's
up goes on top bracha you talked enough
and welcome everybody to the year's best
anime videos 26 feed our special episode
after 14 weeks or so love doing week's
best anime videos we are now going to do
the year's best anime videos 2016 good
as always all the links are in the
description and a happy 2017 everyone
help your new year now we're going to
break this down into a few categories
and the first category that we want to
start with is skits or comedy skits and
we know a bit about these things because
we tried our hand in making some skits
in the past some of you guys from the
channel might know and we had a lot of
fun with them there were a lot of work
but there were a lot of fun and the
first video that I want to discuss is
anime in real life by nigahiga so goes
in what did you think of the video I
thought it was a classic nigahiga video
and I love that he usually incorporates
his love for anime into his work and
this was an example of that I big anime
fan I love it and I love his puns UK I
can't get enough though jess one pun man
yeah that was awesome that was my
favorite part of the one fun man it was
like excellent yeah I bought we watched
[ __ ] all the time and we really wanted
he's an anime fan and he's really
bringing anime into the mainstream
because of course he's got tens of
millions of subscribers that video has
over 10 million 10 million now yeah so
it's an excellent video I'm unit
hilarious obviously [ __ ] knows his
anime well he knows all the tropes he
knows how to you know make fun of all
the cliches and anime in a really great
way and I just loved the video not
another channel that's been doing some
really funny skits anime really it's
kids is our DC world one and back last
in 2015 they drop their first taking
anime too far video that went viral and
then last year in 2016 they drop some
more parts to that video including a
taking anime too far part 2 and i just
love i love all these videos i really
happy I discovered these guys are DC
world one what did you think of them I
love those videos personally and that's
that's literally since I always started
doing this year kind of doing those
anime skits so as from one creating
anime skits for us and then watching
them do it I mean I thought it was
awesome as soon as I found it I have to
show you right because we saw some
amazing things including the first
season when the first episode sorry
where they used the hajime no ippo
dempsey role as a way to defeat the
opponent I use that against the animal
all the time I don't know what to do
okay it's attacking the fence at the
same time spit in his face yeah rdc
world 1 keep it up guys you were awesome
and the last kid that I want to talk
about in this little section is post con
depression by our friend Mackel maxima
now this year we went to uh in the end
of May we went to anime north and that
was the first time we actually showed
our faces so the video to be uploaded
that came out in June the vlog from
anime north was the first time we
actually showed our faces on camera so
that was a big deal for us yeah and
while i was looking at other videos from
anime north i stumbled upon this video
called a post con depression
and i miss workshops and tasty food
meeting people with the same entry says
you almost died of heat stroke at least
four [ __ ] times I not tell mala
missing all the naruto and bleach I mean
come on how could you not want to be
best friends with this guy i know that
mustache is dangerous oh such a chick
magnet yeah that takes some courage man
especially when I matched up with his
cosplay of an amazing female characters
like Marco Menma Menma oh man nursing a
better looking men rock anyways you
definitely check out Mac Mackel not he's
a great youtuber you can up the link is
in the description and this video is
just amazing great job Mac and now let's
talk about some funny animal videos this
year that we saw that were actually
animated and I want to start off with
what could be my favorite video of the
year all together definitely for comedy
and that's giggles reesie row in eight
minutes now if you've seen re0 and you
went through the whole experience and
you kind of went through this
frustrations of the show and the dobson
the downs you will love this video it's
absolutely hilarious gig accuses really
professional voice actors the editing is
amazing and I just I mean I laughed out
loud watching this video the first time
I laughed about the second time I've
been rewatching it over and over again
just awesome what did you think goes on
he knows how to pick up the parts that
may be lacking or maybe not totally
clear and make him hilarious emphasize
them and I thought he did a great job
with this one I can't wait to see the
next anime another really quick video
that I like was a little skit called if
uno was anime which makes it's got two
combines the game of uno with a sort of
yugioh type extreme anime card game and
this is just a hilarious little skit
it's only like a minute and a half
definitely check this out guys you will
enjoy it alright guys next we're going
to be discussing some of the biggest
things that happen in the anime
community in 2016 we got a baby we got a
crazy relationship but no one saw coming
everyone saw coming and everyone saw it
coming and and some cool exciting trips
to Japan so yeah let's talk about it
first I want to talk about aki dearest
enjoyed the anime man getting together
we're saying that they're in love
congrats guys yeah congratulations that
was really cool i really enjoyed when i
saw those videos pop up at the same time
on both of their channels i was like oh
snap what's gonna happen and then i
watch the whole video both videos and
there it was pretty awesome it was it
was even cute I dare say another huge
announcement that we had this year in
the anime YouTube community was misty
crow nexia AKA matt announcing that he
and his wife are expecting a baby bear
baby that's credit is huge news what
what remember when you first saw that
what do you think yeah i mean this this
is what I think like this anime
community again we're going to be
talking about that because the anime
YouTube community is kind of what we
mainly discuss in this channel and just
the fact that you know it's growing and
it's we're getting older as well and
we're having our own kids are gonna be
anime like fans and anime part of the
anime community so it's very exciting
and I look forward to seeing how this
community grows even as the main members
get older yeah exactly adults can love
anime and they can then teach their kids
to love anime I think that's a really
cool thing and yeah missed he also
proved that he's not a virgin once and
for all yeah I mean I was those big news
right I'll that baby video that Ricky
breaking news we couldn't be sure but no
congratulations misty Jess
congratulations guys that is awesome
news all the best in 2017 and finally we
had some crazy trips to Japan this year
we had occupy rest of course go to Japan
to visit to Joey D anime man I assume
his last name is the anime man right
it's just like Joey not all named the
other missiles Austin that's that's
illegally its if it's not we're changing
it that's how it is gonna be from now on
well yeah she went to Japan to visit
Joey and lost paws noble from lost paws
also went to Japan and he also visited
Joey Joe so yeah like a week um yeah I
feel like I feel like when we go to
Japan we gotta visit Joey we got status
place and Roses expand yeah yeah and he
said I was a pretty cool guy right so if
say someone's a pretty cool guy you kind
of have to like put him up at your place
when you go to Japan right now in terms
of sub content that I thought was really
important really kind of got to me
emotionally I really enjoyed a Joey the
mmm he's been making some really
important i feel videos for the anime
industry he's been making videos about
how mangaka are underappreciated and
underpaid in the anime industry he made
a video where he was raising money to
help the anime industry to help
struggling animators and he actually
managed to get his followers and fans to
help out the initiative and they raised
way more money than they were actually
hoping to raise which is awesome news so
yeah I definitely thought that was
really cool of Joey to do I think he's
kind of been leading the pack on this
issue and I feel like we should all
support him and support y anime industry
and hopefully in 2017 we can continue to
make even bigger strides towards this
kind of stuff now another video that I
really loved and this only came out I
think we can have a go two weeks ago was
akis jibley video ah okies video about
the legacy of Studio Ghibli and she's
actually said that she wants to make
more of these videos in the future well
and I'm really looking forward to
because these are my favorite videos
she's she's done it did a great job with
them she goes really into the details
she's done her homework her research she
clearly loves the movies and it really
brings me back to when I was watching
all those movies and I still watch him
and we watched him all the time she used
some really good music that gets you the
fields get you feel it feels feel that
nostalgia so yeah I really love the love
that video I love all her content but
that's my favorite so you know I more
people need to see this stuff and the
ironic thing is don't make me mad guys
more people need to see the stuff the
ironic thing is those videos usually
take a lot more effort force you guys
you know we need to help out users are
putting in the effort and doing all that
work because they're producing great
[ __ ] yeah so all the millions of people
watching this video right now go and
watch okies jublee video and another
recent upload that I wanted to talk
about in this video if you want to see a
roundup of the actual anime the best
anime of 2016 and what happened in the
world of men 2016 rather than just us
talking about YouTube videos you should
check out giggles 2016 anime roundup he
uploaded it in two parts yeah the second
part just came out the other day Oh like
a day before new years or something like
that and as always cook does a great job
and for me personally these videos are
always very useful even catching up to
what the political events that happen in
the past year and having his amazing
commentary cook there's always hilarious
and of course if we couldn't didn't have
enough time to watch or keep up with all
the anime he gives us important stuff in
a humorous way and we gotta love him for
that gives us what we need and because
we have a tradition in this series to
always and off with an amv I thought we
would talk about 2am vs that really
stood out to us this year the what was
the first one so the first one is gonna
be a more professionally made one it's
gonna be of course shelter shelter by
Porter Robinson which obviously took the
internet by storm with it first came up
the anime community I think it's so like
amazing that they did something like
that a lot the only thing I can compare
it to was that punk what they did
interstellar and now we have this
amazing little short film that goes so
well with the music and I think they
really docked it out of the park and if
you guys want to see more about behind
the scenes which I found fascinating you
can check it out at crunchy rolls
YouTube page and the second a movie that
I want to talk about is a nanny called
Falling Skies a Black Lagoon AMV by
warlocks amvs and I really really
enjoyed the San me because I think Black
Lagoon is an underrated anime and I
really like the song I really like how
it went with the song and I just want to
talk about warlocks AMV furs and ambe's
for a second because he makes daily
AMD's they are such great content he
does live streams where he'd like talk
chops with people and shows them how he
makes the m/v psy I just really love his
channel I think everyone should check it
out check out his AMD's and this one in
particular as a fan of Black Lagoon I
really enjoyed however you were
discretion is advised for this one
there's violence there's some swearing
so yeah be advised just a side note I
think it's great that you've been
including Andes and the weekly roundup
because I mean I always loved ammi's
making Andy's watching hamdi's and I
think it's a underappreciated art form
yeah
I love the fact that you know we're
doing our part to spread awareness of
good I gave a million people are
watching this mill exactly Julie one day
but dog it's true goals and as always a
lot of damn bees he made envies himself
on the first video that we uploaded on
our channel long time ago before we were
up late ugh Adam regularly was an EMV
that I really love Naomi doc she loved
for clannad so yeah with electronic
music actually with trance music so I
better first got sick and that's it for
this year guys and yeah I think it was a
good year I of course there were many
more great anime videos that we couldn't
include with them time to clear we
didn't even watch yes oh yeah the course
right so we can watch everything but if
you guys want to recommend certain
videos for us continue to recommend them
in the comments get in touch with us or
on social media because we are going to
continue the week's best anime videos
every week in the new year in 2017 and
I'm looking forward to it yeah i mean
this year has been crazy we only started
posting regular videos with us in them
in the summer in jail so i mean the
amount of support we've gotten since
then and the amount of subscribers and
just how awesome and how responsive and
how much you guys have been active in
the community we're trying to build we
appreciate that so much we're doing r &
cafe every thursday at five p.m. eastern
standard time if you want to check that
out live streams where we discuss hot
topics in the world of anime with
special guest youtubers we're going to
keep doing those we love doing those so
yeah guys stay tuned a lots more to come
here on our channel we really appreciate
your support we really appreciate that
you're watching this right now and until
next time see you space cat was
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]